hier soir a eu lieu ce qu'on appelle le
choc des titans un combat de boxe entre
deux influenceurs Dylan Thierry et
Benjamin Samat
pour préparer ce combat Dylan était à
fond il a pas hésité à se jeter des
glaçons sur le dos à transpirer à
grosses goutte à se faire pourchasser
par des motocross et même à écouter du
gros son avec ses potes
autant vous dire qu'avec cette
entraînement de malade Dylan a juristes
très humble je me prépare pour
l'affronter et pour qu'il goûte le tapis
de Marseille je vais monter sur le ring
et que je vais le manger je vais le
bouffer et face à lui Benjamin s'est mis
un pense-bête pour ne pas se tromper
d'adversaires une fois sur le ring et
après avoir senti leur plus beau slip
pour la peser les deux boxeurs se sont
retrouvés sur le ring à Marseille la
ville de Benji et un peu moins celle de
Dylan visiblement
le combat a donné l'occasion de réaliser
que les commentateurs de boxe ne sont
pas hyper Calais niveau à cupibles
et après un combat en trois rounds c'est
finalement Benjamin qui a réussi à
s'imposer
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
l'équipe de TPMP a bien une échoola
Dylan va pulvériser tu vas venir les
papiers
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant il a un petit peu de
boulot
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je suis en train de chercher le mot
Tanner non mais Dylan qui s'est passé
mon frérot j'aime bien
il s'était très bien entraîné il était
vraiment très fort je l'ai un peu
sous-estimé et 15 secondes après après
le premier round je me suis pété
l'épaule c'est vrai à la plancher direct
ouais du coup je me suis battu avec la
main droite et je suis pas non plus
Mohamed Ali pour pour le battre juste
avec une main
non non je suis droitier
j'ai bien aimé ton ton attitude à la fin
et c'est ça est-ce que ce que vous
pensez de ce projet alors qui a été fait
est-ce que Mathieu trouve ça bien ou pas
parce que c'est vrai que franchement
c'était un beau spectacle non j'ai pas
ouais non non honnêtement c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal maintenant c'est c'est
c'est normal tu vois trois round ou pas
je t'explique
vous êtes parti là dans tous les deux
vous êtes entraîné vous êtes remis en
question donc moi je trouve que c'est
que positif et en plus j'aime bien le
côté chambrage parce que vous êtes à
Marseille et vous rentrez sur la musique
de ici c'est Paris ouais c'est ça déjà
ouais c'était compliqué pour vous dire
tu es content d'avoir fait ça même tu es
très content ouais ça reste du sport
mais j'aurais ma revanche et cetera si
je me prêterai pas l'épaule bien sûr
alors je veux bien je veux bien être
avec toi sur la route
qui était
avec toi avec plaisir
je vois des choses
à Paris avec plaisir
[Applaudissements]
sur le plateau exactement
[Rires]
le temps de couper ouais
parce que c'est Éric non mais c'est il y
a pas des femmes qui veulent faire ça
ok ah c'est une super idée ils ont vendu
plein de pages ils ont fait des millions
de vues sur les réseaux et souvent on se
demande quel est l'avenir des stars de
la télé parce que les émissions marchent
bien moi je pense que c'est ça c'est des
événements parce que même si les
programmes marche moins c'est quand même
des stars ils ont des millions d'abonnés
sur sur les réseaux sociaux il faut
capitaliser sur l'envoi que c'est un
vrai succès et qu'il y a plein de gens
qui ont suivi cet événement et en plus
c'est très bonne esprit c'est pas du
tout violent donc franchement on a on a
Benjamin qui est là le vainqueur du
combat ça lui Benji bravo
[Applaudissements]
bravo
à l'heure et j'ai dit c'est quoi ça tu
es la dernière fois sur le plateau
[Musique]
deux semaines ça veut dire que j'avais
fait que la moitié du travail encore
deux semaines pour travailler mon
maximum est-ce que tu vas continuer la
box que tu t'es dit c'est un kiffe tu
vas continuer mais franchement ça a été
un kiff et je sais que Dylan il a le
droit sa revanche ah bravo que parce que
Ben bien sûr il a il a porté ses
sur le ring de Marseille et il a le
droit d'avoir sa revanche surtout que ça
a été vraiment un très très belle
événement on a kiffé lui comme moi là
c'était beau un peu plus moi que lui
bien évidemment bien sûr
mais franchement c'était trop bien trop
bas excitant et c'est l'une des
premières fois depuis des années des
années qu'on réussit à remplir une
remplir une salle en boxe anglaise en
France donc ça a été un événement
mission accompli pour nous en fait en
gros mission accomplie merci Benjamin en
tout cas d'avoir écrit salut on va dire
on se revoit pour la revanche
un petit peu quand même si t'avais pas
eu l'épaule il était un peu tu ou bien
il était un petit peu au-dessus
ouais en fait parce que j'ai pas son
boxer un peu différente
il bouge à gauche à droite il envoie des
coups à tout va du coup et je vous fais
de la boxe
mais tu es trop sur le visage faut que
tu ailles le chercher un peu en bas sur
le corps France je note non mais c'est
vrai
ou pas je pense je pense que c'est trop
été chercher il faut que tu ailles le
chercher un peu en bas foire et les deux
hein tu regardes le combat les deux vis
que la tête et et Benjamin ouais mais
surtout Dylan en fait le problème c'est
comme Benjamin
avait tapé dans le foie plusieurs fois
il leur a couché avant la tête aussi et
alors mon Dylan j'ai vu que tu t'étais
embrouillé avec un ami avec un mot avec
mon Booba ah mais ça c'est ça va c'est
une histoire d'amis ouais voilà frère
ouais je sais je sais je l'aime pas
toucher
on a conseillé
mais dans le combat il est chambres avec
la musique de Paris s'entraîneur
je vous aime beaucoup
Cyril ça a été une souffrance hein
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis fier d'être un bonheur ils
ont eu des cochonnesses franchement ils
ont lancé un truc et moi j'aime les gens
qui prennent des risques et qui lancent
des trucs et qui restent pas les mecs
qui restent chez eux qui prennent aucun
risque
au moins ils ont lancé un truc et je
peux vous dire que c'est les premiers à
le faire vous allez voir comment ça va
derrière la boxe la boxe c'est c'est un
sport exceptionnel et je trouve que
c'est un sport on le dit c'est le noble
a et c'est vrai que c'est bien parce que
je vois le fair-play qui a entre les
deux j'ai bien aimé Dylan qui applaudi à
la fin quand quand Benjamin est désigné
vainqueur
mérite sa revanche
ça va générer ça va générer encore des
sous donc c'est normal mais c'est c'est
le business c'est le truc oui Delphine
et comme quoi la préparation
psychologique c'est important aussi
parce que par exemple Benji lui il
s'entraînait face à une photo de toi il
avait une photo de toi est-ce que toi tu
as aussi fait ça non non parce que ça
c'est la visualisation en fait et ça
aide et c'est ce que j'avais dit sur le
plateau c'est pas forcément la personne
physiquement qui est la plus forte c'est
la visualisation c'est non mais tu
parles de préparation mentale c'est un
tocard il s'est fait
[Applaudissements]
suite nous gonfle avec ta boxe
[Rires]
qui m'a défié
on a fait 10 combats il a dit
moi je veux bien aller contre vous au
point excusez-moi
les pieds je voudrais bien que j'ai le
genou qui est un peu je te casserai le
genou
et puis voilà comme ça ce sera réglé en
tout cas Dylan moi je te dis voilà il y
avait un bon niveau boxe
je vous jure les mecs pénible et vous
étiez pas ridicule bravo donc
très bien très bien démonstrations
[Applaudissements]
je veux voir ça je veux voir ça
[ __ ] incroyable
ça fait du bien